- [Speaker] Hi everyone.
Thanks for turning the today's session.
So we'll go over why knowledge graphs
are great for AI and agentic AI
and we'll see how it makes your AI
more trustworthy and explainable, right?
So we'll go through that.
So what's the agenda?
We'll go through some
of the AI challenges we
have with enterprise data
understanding context engineering.
Some of you already know that term.
We'll go over what is context engineering
and why knowledge drives really help
to build that context
and make your data AI ready.
I've not have time to
go through a demo today
because a lot of slides,
but if you stop by a booth,
I think it's 1212 booth number,
we'll go through the demo and you can also
understand our new agents and MCP servers
and stuff like that.
So let's score some of
the challenges we have,
especially with the
enterprise data, right?
As you all know, AI is a
great accelerant, right,
for new experiences and processes.
It really defines, you know,
to get new drive innovation,
reduce complexity,
improve experiences, all
of that to lower cost,
grow revenue, manage risk.
So there is definitely a
lot of adoption with AI,
but you'll be surprised
to know that only 5%
of the projects actually go
into production, right?
95% don't go, don't reach production.
So this is the new report report
from MIT and Gartner's study
where it shows that only 20%
of the projects actually do a POC
and of that only 5% go to production.
So a lot of the survey
that we surveyed customers say
that the data is not AI ready, right?
So that's a reason
why they don't go to production.
The reason might be the data is in silos,
there might be security constraints,
there are a lot of regulations
and stuff like that, right?
So those are the main reasons.
So we'll get into some of that.
So here's some of the AI challenges
around enterprise data, right?
So we know there's
hallucinations obviously,
but that's improving on
the public internet data.
But on the enterprise
data, it still needs a lot
of improvement and AI really
is like a black box, right,
where enterprise don't really get you
all the data to customers,
and there's a lot of regulations
and compliance around data, right?
Those are the main reasons.
And other big reason
is the context, right?
So you really don't have a structured
or connected context switch context
that we can give to LLMs.
We'll get into that a little bit,
but those are the main reasons, right?
So what we have done is we have bucketed
that into three big buckets.
There's a data organization problem
where your data can live
in many data sources, right?
You can have data warehouses,
lake houses, traditional
relation databases,
document stores, and so on.
So AI really cannot
access that information.
So that's a challenge.
The other is,
you might have different schemas, right?
Schemas, data models, format structures.
So AI cannot really understand,
sometimes interpret that information.
So that's another challenge.
So those first two,
it's easy to interpret,
like a lot of enterprises
are actually working on that.
The third one is a big challenge
where scale of query diversity, right,
so let me go a little deeper on that.
Query diversity is a big problem
where you ask a question to LLM right,
now with the enterprise
data, you have a lot
of information, lot of sources to gather,
take information and query.
So it's not one query,
it's not a one question
to one query, right?
So you have lot of queries to gather
and then get to a solution.
Let me give you an example, right?
Let's take a supply chain optimization
as a use case.
And the question is,
you wanna find the best routes
from point A to point B.
That's your problem, that's
your question, right?
But now you have to deal
with a lot of data sources.
You might have to get into ERP systems,
your data warehouses,
many of those sources.
Now you start asking deeper,
probably you want to say,
"You know what, I wanna
identify possible routes,
I want to trace dependency chains.
I want to ask the delays
and the lead times."
So you start asking those questions.
So that basically it's a lot of query.
So now you are hitting it
with a query diversity problem, right?
So there are two ways to fix that.
Either give a lot more context to the LLM
so that it understands
or consolidate the data somehow
so you have a simpler query, right?
So that's exactly what we're trying to do.
Graphs help you do that.
It obviously boosts accuracy
and improve explainability.
And the reason why you're here
for the the stock is
it actually allows you
to get you more context
and make the data AI ready, right?
We'll get to that in a bit.
So before that, let's understand
what is context engineering.
Some of you already know that term here.
It's basically a evolution
of prompt engineering, right?
So by definition it says
that you just give enough information
to the LLM so that it
can get to the next stage
or next step, right?
So you want the right data,
at the right time, at the right structure
so it knows what to do next.
So why does it matter now?
I mean, traditionally or even now,
like what's happening is you expect
one shot LLM prompts, right?
So you give an answer, you ask a question,
or you think that you'll give an answer
that's very straightforward,
but that's not the case
with enterprise data, right?
You have like multiple data sources.
It has to reason.
So especially with agentic AI,
it has to reason, it has to plan.
You have multi-step actions,
you probably call multiple tools.
So it has to fetch data,
all of that, right?
So again, it comes back to the query.
So it has to do multiple queries
to get that information.
So what we're saying is
give the enough context
so it understands what to do next, right?
So that's a basic idea.
Again, that's a definition
by LangChain as well.
So what are some of the
sources you have, right?
So you have all the user interactions
that you give to the LLMs.
Now that can be your
prompts, your feedback
and all the interactions
you have with LLMs.
It keeps the state and history.
So that's also can be part of the context.
It has a short term long-term memory
within the models so that
that can also be used.
You have structured output,
that is basically your APIs and data tools
that you fetch data from, right?
That is also part of the context.
That other big thing is a RAG.
So now you can actually
retrieve information
from your vector database or your GraphRAG
where you have like a graph database
like NEO4j and that can be part
of the context, right?
So those are some of the sources.
And this is the same view,
but from a different angle
where you have human interactions,
you have cognitive layer of application,
you have memory layer of the models,
and you have data tools, right, the APIs.
It's the same thing,
but just laid out on a different view.
So the other big thing
which we need to consider,
just because you have
data, I cannot give all
that information to the LLMs.
It's gonna hallucinate again, right,
'cause it has too much information
just as a context.
So what we are saying is
there's something called
as a minimal viable context.
Just for the definition
of context engineering,
again, it's just the right information
for the LLMs to do the next step, right?
So we have to make sure you have higher
signal-to-noise ratio,
right to get to the LLMs.
So that's another concept basically
with context engineering.
So at the crux, that's what it is, right?
You give the right information.
Even if you have agentic models,
agents should understand what to do next.
So you need that context information.
So why graphs?
So before I dig in...
Oh, hold on.
So before I dig in,
what is graph database itself,
so let's understand a concept
of knowledge graphs, right?
So basically by definition,
it's a design pattern
to organize and access
connected data, right?
You can have any connected data,
everything is connected, right?
So let's say you have a supply chain,
you have financial data,
you have networking,
access control, all of
that is connected, right?
So by definition,
you can have a supply
chain knowledge graph,
you can have a financial knowledge graph,
you can have any of the
knowledge graphs, right?
So now it has specific information
around that, right?
The way we store data is something called
as a property graph model.
Instead of tables and columns,
we have nodes and relationships, right?
So again, coming back to the supply chain,
think of a supplier and
a raw materials, right?
Supplier is a node,
and raw materials is a node as well.
Supplier supplies raw materials.
Supplies, it's a word,
that's a relationship.
So that's how we store data.
And within that information,
you can store properties, right?
I can say, hey, supplier
supplies raw materials,
but what's the date it's supplied on?
What's the lead time?
What's the capacity?
So those are the properties.
Now that is the context
that you can store inherently
within the database, right?
So that's a big, big difference.
So I don't have to have JOINs and tables
and to extract data.
Everything is inherently stored, right?
So think of this as
another example, right?
So you have supplier,
so now I have supplier graph,
I have a product graph,
I have a consumer graph.
So now all your business
can be all connected
in one view, right?
So now it solves two problems.
Like I was saying,
you have the query diversity problem.
It's simpler to query with graph databases
because you have all the connected view.
I can do a multi hop query,
I can do reasoning all of that
because it's everything's connected
and inherently stored, right?
The other big challenge which we solve
by this is giving the
right context, right?
So now I can give a minimal context
to the LLMs for that to
do the next step, right?
So that's the reason why we say
it's a AI ready data
because you have all the
connections and context
within the database.
Again, it's the same thing.
I'm not gonna go through that again.
So think of this as a left
and right brain, right?
So right brain is basically your language,
reasoning, creativity.
And then your left brain is basically
your knowledge layer, right?
So you have context enrichment.
Together, obviously you
have more explainable AI.
So that's the whole idea.
Coming back to RAG, this is part
of the context engineer, right?
So you're trying to provide
as much context as possible.
That's the whole idea, right?
So traditionally what you have
is you have a retriever
where you retrieve information
from a vector database, right?
It can be NoSQL or vector database.
With graph, it's basically
you're replacing that
with a graph database
and that's a GraphRAG.
That's all, right.
But what we have now
is since we have the connected view
of all the information,
you have the context.
Now I can provide a
lot more richer context
to the LLMs.
So that's a whole idea
with the GraphRAG right.
Now, example would be
going back to supply chain,
the same question I asked before, right?
What's the best route
from point A to point B?
With graph, I don't have to dig deeper
into ERP solutions, spreadsheets,
dashboards and all of that, right?
I can just do a single query saying,
"What's the shortest path?"
That's a query, that's
an algorithm I can use,
and you get the answer.
It's as simple as that, right?
So that makes it much easier.
Also, you have other information
that you can retrieve, right?
You can do pattern matching, path finding.
You have community driven algorithms
that you can retrieve
from the graph databases.
So it gives you an added benefit
of using a graph database, right?
So again, just to hit on
the architecture here,
so you have a data platform that can be
since we're the AWS conference,
it can be anything, right,
Aurora Redshift, S3 buckets and whatnot.
You have LLM and knowledge graph
can sit in between that
as a context layer or a
knowledge layer, right?
So a lot of companies, what they do is,
they project the data
from your traditional data platforms
into knowledge graph.
You don't have to project everything.
You can just project
part of the data there
where you wanna run algorithms
or where you need the context from.
And that can act as a context to LLMs.
So a lot of companies are doing that.
That just gives you an idea
of how you wanna use knowledge graphs.
And also the knowledge graphs
lead to more accuracy.
And this is not me saying it.
This is the public report
which you can access.
They've run a study
where they run knowledge graphs
against NoSQL and SQL databases
and they've found that the accuracy
is 3x more accurate
in terms of responses they get from LLMs.
So just to level set, right, why is that?
Let's go to the semantics of it, right?
Let's say have you have very
simple example of apples and oranges.
On the left, you can query, right?
That's how it's stored.
I don't have a vector representation.
That's how it's stored
in the graph database.
On the right, it's a vector database.
It's a vector embeddings.
That's how you store
the information, right?
To do a search, you
probably do a Euclidean,
or a Cosine, a similarity search.
On the left, on the graph database,
it's very easy.
You can just query, right?
You can do a lot more with it
like pattern matching, path finding
and a lot of those things
with the graph database.
And imagine now that
you have just one information now, right?
So let's say you have supplier graph,
product graph, consumer graph,
all of that information,
now you can really analyze the data,
you can do a lot more with it.
Not only giving the context to LLMs,
but you can do a lot more with it, right?
So in essence that's advantage
of using a graph database.
So this is my last slide.
Really, graphs go beyond GraphRAG, right?
So like I was mentioning,
you have context engineering
where you give the right level of context.
It allows you to do that
because it has all the information stored
within the graph database, right?
Also, when you're interacting,
all the user interactions
you have with LLMs,
you can store that as
context as well, right?
Within the RAG architecture, you can go,
like after the response,
you have all the interactions.
You can store that as context.
You can probably store that as a property
or relationships or nodes
within the graph database.
So you have that as a memory, right?
You can use that as a context as well.
Beyond that you can
obviously visualize it.
The other thing which we didn't talk
about is a Cypher query.
It's a GQL query.
Just like a SQL, you have a GQL.
GQL is graph query language.
Using that you can do a lot of things
like pattern matching,
path finding and so on.
So that really allows you to visualize
and explore data even further.
I think that's all I had
and if you have any questions,
we have booth 1212
and then we can probably go through demo.
I didn't have time for the demo.
I had a demo but I didn't have time.
But if you can come through our booth,
we'll go through demo.
We also have our agents
and other MCP service as well.
Thanks for coming.
(audience clapping)